How much trouble would you want there
not to be?
It's a weird question,
right?
Because you want to have something to
contend with.
You want to have something that that
forces from you the best that you have,
and so you have to have real problems.
Something like that.
Would you dispense with all your real.
You could just lay down on a bed and
have pablum infused into your mouth.
You know if all your problems were
solved and so maybe you want difficult
problems that you can solve.
Something like that because there's
some.
I don't know what it is about it.
There's A.
There's the overcoming and the and the
growth that comes along with that.
There's something about the nobility of
the enterprise.
You certainly see that when you go about
having children,
for example,
which is,
you know,
the psychological literature is quite
clear if,
if you do moment to moment comparisons
of people who have kids and people who
don't have kids,
the people who don't have kids are
happier and so psychologists who tend to
get things wrong,
even when they make intelligent
discoveries like that one,
immediately some of them jumped to the
conclusion that because happiness is the
goal,
that while there's something about
children that make you unhappy and
that's not good,
it's like,
well,
wait a second,
and maybe that's the wrong metric.
It's like,
of course you're less happy once you
have children because you have to worry
about them.
You know,
my neighbor down the street who's very
smart woman said to me once,
you can only be as happy as your
unhappiest child,
which I thought was really good.
You know,
that's really smart,
but then it isn't.
Well,
it's having children doesn't make you
happy.
The answer isn't,
don't have children.
It's like,
don't be so stupid about being happy.
That's the answer.
It's because there's a nobility in the
pursuit,
right?
And of course now you're responsible,
you know you have a new baby.
You think especially if you're a new
parent,
you think,
what the hell is this and what am I
gonna do with it?
You know,
it's like,
and then you're,
you're done for the rest of your life.
You never sleep properly again because
you're going to be worried about this
creature that you have to take care of
it,
but like,
what the hell good are you?
If you're not doing that or something
else equally difficult because you just,
you just have been called out yet.
Unless you take on a responsibility like
that,
the idea that life is that happiness is
the purpose of life.
It's like great for happiness,
man.
If it comes along,
you should be thrilled that it's
visiting you,
but the notion that that's,
that that's what you should pursue.
That's,
that's the weakest possible notion.
First of all,
as soon as something terrible happens to
you,
you're done.
It's like life is to be happy.
It's like,
well,
now you have cancer,
so how's that?
How's the happiness thing?
Work it out for you now,
or maybe it's not you.
You know,
maybe it's your father that has
Alzheimer's disease or some damn thing
and you know it's like it's a rare
person that doesn't have some
catastrophe.
One,
one person away from them.
It's like life is to be happy.
It's that's not right,
and we can at least derive that from
these stories.
That isn't what they say at all.
God's perfectly happy in the stories to
grant the people with whom he forms a
covenant happiness and prosperity,
but there's never a word that that's the
purpose.
The rule is aim high and get your bloody
act together.
That's the rule and establish this
contractual covenant with the ultimate
ideal and that will see you through the
catastrophes and that's a much more
mature way of looking at life as far as
I'm concerned because all you have to do
is have your eyes half open and you see
that the fundamental reality of life is
tragedy and suffering.
There's that's inescapable.
The quest.
That doesn't mean that it.
It makes life unbearable or that it
makes being something that shouldn't
have existed,
right?
That isn't what it means,
but it means that you have to contend
with it and you have to get ready and
the willingness to adopt responsibility
for yourself and for others is,
is the precondition for that.
And then maybe if you do that properly,
then now and then you get some
happiness.
You know,
you can sit at the end of the day and
you have half an hour where your
conscience is clear and there's nothing
that you need to be doing and you can
relax and think,
you know,
that that's all right.
Things are okay and thank God for that.
And that's,
that's maybe where you get your
happiness.
So that's something that's growing up,
man,
obviously,
and,
and to not know that and to not be
taught that,
like everyone should be taught that it's
so obvious.